this is from a tall guy nh what are
some top things that directors do or
don't do that drive you crazy
one of the big things is the director
talks over the performance
will be coaching the actor to do certain
things during a performance and
they'll be stepping on each other's
lines and
uh you know an extension of that
is when actors are stepping over each
other
stepping on each other's lines the
director
won't sort of
gently kind of ask them to try to be
aware of your overlaps
overlaps or a pain in the butt you know
they can be dealt with
but quite often they can't and they'll
just have to be looped so
that's a couple what about in scenes
where it's intentional
where they're they're two people having
an argument they're interrupting each
other they're both angry
yeah i mean you know again uh
you know that sort of like just comes
down to sort of you know
finally finessing your dialogue edits
and attaching
the maybe the part the first part of the
word that's overlapped
to the second part of the word that's
clean on the other side
so there's all kinds of tricks you can
you know work around it with
but you know you know some of the time
you're just gonna have to loop it anyway
and uh
that's a drag because the performances
are um
you know unless you've got a great
looper they're they're usually never as
good
this question is from robert knees
differences in editing for single camera
or multi-camera production
well you know i've worked on a lot of
films with multiple cameras i've never
worked on like a three-camera comedy
kind of a thing so i can only i can only
address
uh working with multiple cameras
i love working with multiple cameras um
you know it just gives you more choices
it makes matching easier a lot of the
times
when stuff is shot with a single camera
a lot of times
you know you'd you might
well frankly you're gonna have to work
harder to make it to make it work
uh sometimes again this depends on the
actor
it depends on the director it depends on
the day you know there's so many
variables in making a film
uh i love
i love multi-camera i mean
sometimes when it gets to be five six
seven cameras it gets a bit overwhelming
but uh you know they keep making those
cameras smaller and smaller and uh they
keep putting them in
in the strangest of places so uh it's
just
you know it's just what the senators
have to deal with
you